remembering fallen trooper micah may
while saving a life nevada highway
patrol is teamed up with by talent to
host a blood drive in honor of the
fallen trooper this morning bianca
holman shares how you can participate
and joins us live this morning from nhp
headquarters bianca good morning
hey good morning john so we are near
sunset and decatur the headquarters of
nhp and this is where the blood drive
will be right here
starting at 10 a.m and ending at 5 p.m
and it again is all in honor of trooper
micah may trooper micah may was laid to
rest on friday he was hit while trying
to stop a carjacking suspect and he
didn't make it passing away at umc
hospital a father husband brother and
son those close to him say he dedicated
his life to selfless service so in honor
of may's courage and integrity nevada
highway patrol is holding a blood drive
to help save lives brittany estrella
vitalent says people who are in
chemotherapy and those who need blood
transfusion from car crashes childbirth
or sickle cell are in dire need of
donations
o negative is a type of blood that is
the universal blood type and there is an
urgent need for this type specifically
because this is the blood type that is
utilized in a trauma center situation
when there are seconds remaining to save
the life of a hospital patient
and this
type is specifically needed at this time
but with the pandemic we continue to see
hundreds of blood drives that are
canceled every month due to the pandemic
there are still many business closures
that are taking place right now and a
lot of businesses that are operating
remotely so we encourage anyone who is
feeling healthy and feeling well to come
donate blood
so here are the details listed on your
screen the blood drive at nhp training
room from 10 a.m to 5 p.m takes about an
hour of your time from check-in to
donation and then the observation period
so you can register in advance but again
they will have some spots open for
walk-ins but again they encourage you to
plan in advance and register online also
be sure to bring a mask all those
donating and of course employees and
workers here at nhp will be wearing
their mass following guidelines
reporting live from sunset in decatur
bianca holman 8 news now bianca thank
you very much